hey everybody and welcome to a beautiful
wild ride with stevo we've got the
world's most famous plastic surgeon
a guy who makes people beautiful for a
living and he's damn good at it plus i
really wanted to talk to this man dr
terry dubrow because
i'm looking for a plastic surgeon to
work on me and i know that sounds crazy
but it's a hundred percent true and
listen to this juicy ass podcast and you
will find out all about it
also
if you care to have a raging hard boner
the good news is this podcast was
brought to you by blue chew what's blue
chew well blue chew tablets
are delicious chewable tablets which
have the same active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis except it only costs a
fraction of the price i'm telling you it
gives you a raging boner something which
i love to have now you might be thinking
but don't you need a prescription to get
this and
you are right but the good news is you
don't have to go to an awkward in-person
doctor's office visit
now
you just consult with one of their
medical providers online at
bluetooth.com couldn't be easier
couldn't be quicker and then once you're
done with that boom your bluetooth
tablets are on the way and the best news
about it
bluetooth loves the listeners of the
wild ride podcast so much they're giving
you an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets completely for free
all you gotta pay is five bucks for
shipping it doesn't get better than that
and if you're wondering whether this
bluetooth tablet phenomenon actually
makes for a really good time trust me
and trust my girl it does nothing's more
fun than having a raging boner so head
on over to bluechew.com
use the promo code stevo to collect
on this offer for one month's supply
completely for free
and with that said let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
dr terry dubrow
oh well that was good pronounce my name
correctly good job thank you very good
off to a good start this is my co-host
scott randolph hey scott how's it going
up at the front we've got the gorgeous
paul briskey doctor
nice to meet you
so i think that some people will find it
uh counter-intuitive that
yeah
but why why have the
plastic surgeon is it safe to say that
you're the most famous plastic surgeon
in the world i think if you ask me the
answer would be yes
but whether i am or not i mean botch is
on in 164 countries can you believe that
164. wow and so i mean i think if you
were to ask internationally to name two
plastic surgeons it would be
that other guy what does paul i think is
known and then me terry
who's the other guy paul nassif so
there's two guys on the show botched
right okay right right right and so um i
do i'm a head-to-toe plastic surgeon he
just does noses basically and he's a
great guy i
used to do noses but he does them all
but i'm a classically trained plastic
surgeon so i do
a lot of the stuff from head to toe yeah
um and
botched
is is of course what it sounds like
you're kind of uh fixing disasters that
happened with plastic surgery gone wrong
that's pretty much it i mean late we've
done seven seasons where we just got
picked up for two more so eight and nine
we're gonna do 20 more episodes and uh
it started out by
basically fixing people who've had
disasters from plastic surgery it sort
of evolved into like if you're a victim
of trauma or a bad congenital deformity
right whether you've had plastic surgery
or not and you have kind of a hopeless
unfixable situation you come to us and
we
try to do it we pretty much do it yeah
well it's unbelievable she's you said
that uh if you ask anyone in the world
or
in any other place in the world there
they would have two guys and both of
them are from botched yes paul and i it
was the the show was originally paul's
idea we had worked for a short period of
time together and uh he called me up one
day and he goes hey you do a lot of
revisional stuff a lot of fix that i go
yeah so to you he goes why don't we do a
tv show about fixing impossible to fix
plastic surgery i said terrible idea he
goes well i said well think about it
most of it will probably go badly and
we've just put ourselves on national
television
with
disaster complications that we could
have because the risk
of a complication is
exponentially higher when someone's had
previous plastic surgery or when
someone's had 15 previous operations
right so it's it's kind of not a great
idea reputation risk wise
but you know we sort of it you know how
life imposes its will on you and forces
you to do something that even if you
thought was a bad idea you just
do it you get really
good at it and we got really good at it
so i mean that's really interesting do
you find yourself like uh
contractually
in a place where you don't have control
of the
final edit no uh we don't we don't have
control of well we don't we don't really
see the final at it i mean they're very
sort of concerned about see i don't you
probably don't know this but my wife's
up a housewife on real housewives oh wow
paul's wife was a housewife on real
housewives of beverly hills
years ago
and so you have no control over that
edit in fact right they'll make you look
bad they'll make you look sure good you
have no this show they're you know we're
never worried because they always say to
us ride the razor's edge i kind of
i'm a very silly guy naturally and
everything i see i sort of find kind of
off the wall and funny and so i use a
lot of off-color humor
in the show that they can't use okay so
or if they did use it would make me look
really bad because you know when reality
show you do those interviews afterwards
and then you try to say something funny
and wasn't that funny so you try to say
it again and invariably i get dirty with
it and i go okay you can't say that at
all if they showed that i'd be canceled
right so they'll say no matter what
we'll take care of you know they make us
look like heroes on purpose so i'm never
worried about it yeah that's true they
never want you to look bad that's kind
of whereas the real housewives it's like
they need a villain they need a good
girl they need like you don't need that
you don't want a bad doctor right you
don't want a bad doctor but you don't
want just an interesting weird
uncool story is that my wife wasn't on
real housewives of orange county for the
last four years we were on the first
first five years not the first five
years but like seasons 6 to 11 we were
on it
then i got after you're on botch no i've
got i started doing botch about three
seasons into real housewives of orange
county same production company okay so
you figure oh they'll take oh so we were
off the show the same network too is it
all in bravo no we're on e oh okay but
the same company nbcu okay so botch is
on e
real housewives is on bravo we left real
housewives and now i'm just doing botch
which was awesome right really fun you
have to worry about being your
reputation being
being a problem anyway we go back on
real housewives of orange county
and one of the new housewives apparently
i had operated on 20 years ago 20 years
ago and unbeknownst to me because she
looked so different had a different last
name she had sued me
and you just forgot to malpractice i
forgot didn't go anywhere she dropped it
it was no big deal
so she comes on i had no idea it was her
she knew
the other housewives figured it out and
they blew up the story instantly my
production company highlighted on real
housewives orange county a malpractice
lawsuit against me while i'm their hero
on botch and i went to i said are you
guys
smoking crack i'm your you you wanna
anyway it was really a bad idea
it really i felt it really it really
hurt my feelings it was really disloyal
but that's what happened this season on
real housewives wow
how pissed would you be
um
i i can't even imagine but yeah i'm a
very sensitive guy so i imagine i would
be upset i mean to highlight i mean i'm
unboxing these cases and make a big
storyline on a even a bigger show about
a malpractice lawsuit against me yeah
it's just not something anyway
all right yeah that would bump me out
too it bummed me out i i was less
uh
you know motivated to ask about approval
of the of the edit and and you know uh
control over over what they include
about how they show you in in interviews
than
about how they would approach
just failures
okay that's a very good question so it's
you're right uh weirdly in 178 episodes
we really only had about three
go wrong and i mean like presumably
like you said the the risk is
considerably greater in people who have
proven to be prone to things going wrong
or they've had so much plastic surgery
you know it's funny in plastic surgery
you have a disaster complication either
because statistically you're going to
run into a complication or you push your
doctor keep going going bigger keep
doing more surgery just keep doctor
shopping having more and more surgery so
the tissues ruined so yeah the risk in
our surgery is particularly high in fact
i have a special high-risk consent form
i have them sign that says you realize
right this is no joke your chance of a
complication even in our hands who do
this for a living is extraordinarily
high it's as high as 40 percent or more
and of course
they think we're just covering our butts
with this but it's the truth
but to answer your question i three or
four times it went you know we had one
patient end up in the hospital
um but they did okay
where it gets tough is when you have a
patient
who has a complication and then they go
to an attorney who says you know what
harvey levin tmz is going to hear about
this we how about you give us five
million dollars or we're going to expose
this to you like almost an extra that's
happened once on the show this patient
tried to extort me who was on bosch
immediately we fired him from the show
and we said go for it and uh we got the
story out before they did so it didn't
actually and that's why you have
insurance for [ __ ] like that well you
can't have malpractice insurance for
someone you know trashing your
reputation see the big thing with me is
if you sue me that's cool because i
don't commit malpractice i've been doing
this for a long time i'm a certified
expert for the california medical board
i'm a medical legal expert i know
exactly how to do this within the
standard of care but you can get me by
fi just the act of filing a lawsuit
against terry dubrow from botched it's
like a bad yelp review it's the on scale
exactly yeah by the way the big threat
is botched by the botched doctor that's
why when the show first started before
the first episode it was named nip
[ __ ]
nip
asterisks
we thought this is so funny and then
like two weeks before the show the first
episode came out
bravo said the advertisers don't like
that we're changing the name we go okay
what do you change it to we went they
said bosh
that's a disaster why do why didn't we
want to be botched first of all it
implies that some doctor blew it
or
if we
blow it it's botched by the botched
doctor so we just didn't want that
reputational hit so that's always the
threat oh we're going to file a lawsuit
against you not whether the lawsuit will
prevail just the filing of it actually
hurts us because it goes viral
immediately yeah right but
it nip
[ __ ]
it is it has all the same it does but
botched is like somebody blew it that
[ __ ] is is funny you know you have to
get fully past the own nip talked that
[ __ ]
it just didn't have the automatic
you ruined them which botch does so i
mean it is a juicy title and i think
that they did well to go with it they
did and now it's i mean it's part of the
vernacular almost botched you know they
use it for other things as well botched
mission well you always do that but now
it has that particular meaning to it
because it's part of the just like you i
mean it's not as significant as that but
it's part of the cultural
language now um
now
the uh
like the show obviously is very
successful yeah um
does uh
the decline in
television viewership like i mean like
is it propped up by uh by streaming
service i guess the peacock would be so
the ratings and i do follow the ratings
of course you live and die by the
ratings television the
ratings of landscape television have
degraded obviously every single season
weirdly this last season season seven we
went up to back to season five ratings
okay which is interesting that's why
they picked us up for so many episodes
and
it's still grading on a curve so
if the other shows on the network have
degraded
more
by a greater percentage and you went up
you sort of did not only didn't you
degrade down 30 like all tv shows do now
that they go i think
i think the show
um i don't i don't know why it went up i
don't know i don't they gave it a little
breather for a few months but it but it
did better but i i don't know why it
actually
did so well this last season i was in a
hotel room with my fiance
in
november
of last year
and
it was just on on a marathon just one
show after the other and we just sat
there and we were in gross it was it's
the only time i ever watched the show
right and i thoroughly enjoyed it and i
just hung in there for episode after
episode until it was just obnoxiously
late at night
that's funny i think the show the reason
it works is we have this nice
relationship
it's plastic surgery gone bad but
everyone knows you always question the
authenticity of other reality shows i
mean like
what you guys did i mean when you fall
off a building or something everyone
goes that's dangerous they're going to
get hurt they even if they don't they
got luck same with botch it's like we
take this tissue apart that's damaged a
disaster we've warned them this could be
a complete
nightmare with you ending up in the
hospital i'm way worse and everybody
inherently goes yeah that's true that's
no one questions whether it's authentic
and you want to see the outcome you know
and so i think that's
that's why it works and that was the
very thing i was so afraid of because
it's the predictably it
it should go
wrong a lot of the times right my
question
on the
you said three or four times that it
didn't go well did the show own that and
include
those uh
sort of okay so
yeah that's a very question do they so
the answer is
one of the times it didn't go well
um it was because she had a wound
problem
and
she was a stretch problem
her wound popped open okay and it needed
dressing changes
incision the incision popped open and
got infected she needed dressing changes
which is okay because as long as you
treat it and it gets better we're good
but she left a packing in there and it
healed over it it pussed out she ended
up in the hospital and she hired a
lawyer and i said you stuck the packing
in there you know you're supposed to
take it out and that's one person who
tried to extort me so they were off the
show so that's one of the three and
that's not even a call that anybody made
creatively that's just that's like you
you sue us you see the network you're
out right the other two um
they it
it just didn't work the surgery we did
just didn't work very well and
we ended we were going to bring them
back and try to fix them again and they
just the patients lost interest it was
like their 17th surgery but i will tell
you one thing we don't show you on
boxing is the following
a lot of times it looks like we do one
surgery and they're fixed and here's the
after oh thank you dr bill you're the
greatest you know it sometimes we do
four
okay sometimes i try to give people a
90-plus percent improvement right and so
if you are a total
nightmare melted wax thing right the
first sometimes the first big surgery is
trying to get you into the 60s like i
think of it like getting a score on a
test you know right you want to get a 90
that's an a and you need to get like 96
to get in med school but a 93
improvement in plastic surgery is a
really
giant improvement so sometimes with one
surgery i'll get them not very often i
almost always get in the low 90s one
time but sometimes you get them
into the 60s you go okay and then six
weeks later you get them into the 80s
and then you get them into the 90s with
three or four surgeries if you try to
push it into the 90s sometimes with one
surgery
you're going to go the other way and
you're going to make them worse okay or
put them in the hospital now
plastic surgery
is safe to say that it's always elective
surgery and as such not covered by
insurance okay so there's plastic and
reconstructive surgery so
the stuff that's considered
reconstructive like breast cancer
reconstruction a congenital deformity
breasts that are giant those surgeries
that have sort of a functional component
not just a cosmetic
if there's a significant functional
component that's covered by insurance
okay but taking a bump off somebody's
nose not but having an airway a
breathing problem
that's sometimes that is often so
sometimes there's two components and
breast reconstruction even though it's
cosmetic it's pure cosmetic because you
don't have a functional problem when you
have no breasts insurance companies will
pay for that okay
now in the case uh on the show
when you've got four surgeries
um
is the show covering these these
surgeries so
general so the show covers the surgery
wow and they they pay us a certain
amount to do the surgery and then
anything after that we kind of take care
of because i'm not putting you on the
after you know i'm not showing it after
that's
terrible it's got to be rock star so
that would
make me believe that the budget for this
show is pretty astronomical if you're
covering all of this surgery well
98 of the time we nail it with one
operation
so for example let's say the show pays
20 000 to have us operate on the patient
okay
20 000 covers the anesthesia the
facility i might charge normally under
normal circumstances a lot more than
that portion of 20 000 that's the
procedure fee especially if you're
taking a big risk right yeah surgery but
obviously i'm i'm it's just they pay us
enough just to cover it and we're sort
of as far as i'm concerned once i'm in
you know i'm in yeah by the way i kind
of do that with my own patients if you
fly
most of my practice is botched meaning
you don't really come to terry dubrow
because you want a simple bump taken off
the nails or you want
br simple breast enlargement you come to
me because i'm gonna fix your
desperately hopeless problem
if i i charge you a lot of money for it
because i have special skills i mean you
know maybe i'm not tom brady but you
don't pay tom brady you know a million
dollars a year to be your quarterback
you gotta pay him because he's gonna win
right well i'm gonna win i'm gonna i'm
gonna win and so if i don't and you've
flown in from
today i had most of my practice overseas
practices back i had two patients were
from africa today patient from sweden a
patient a bunch from texas new york
you come in you come all the way in we
charge you this amount of money if it
doesn't work i'm going to keep going and
i'm not going to keep charging you every
time right so
we
do you have a favorite body part that
you work on well the most common boobs
could this doctor be any cooler it's
like you want him to be your dad he's so
cool
and let me tell you father's day is
coming up mighty quick which has me
thinking about some of the coolest
things my father taught me like
if a little's good a lot's better
and
never over promise and under deliver
god i love my dad and i'm guessing you
love yours too so why don't we get him
something really cool for father's day
from harry's which is the single company
in the shaving products industry with
the highest customer satisfaction they
just make quality products with no
pricey gimmicks and they're giving their
best offer to the listeners of the wild
ride podcast
plus for father's day you get two cool
choices you can either get if you're a
first time harry's customer
this killer starter kit which comes with
the weighted ergonomic handle the 5
blade razor the cool travel case for the
blade and the foaming shave gel or you
can get free engraving on any premium
shave kit so that dad can have his own
cool engraved razor
how about that now to get this deal you
just go to harry's dot com slash devo
plus i can think of a lot of funny
things i might get engraved on a razor
for my dad just putting that out there
so head to harry's dot com slash stevo
to get this great deal and now let's
find out if this doctor is a boob guy or
a buck guy are you a boob guy or a bug
okay so the most common plastic surgery
procedure is breast augmentation that
happens to be the one that has the most
risks associated with it because you
think about it
you you make an incision you open a
pocket you throw in a foreign body the
immune system comes by and goes what
what is this right and a great
percentage of time it decides at some
point in the future maybe not right away
but maybe a year later three years later
hopefully never it decides i don't like
this and it forms intense scar tissue
around it in cases that called capsular
control actually exactly you learn from
the show that's good
that's exactly what's called capsular
contracture and
you know
you'll go back in you'll try it again
and then it'll get infected and now
you've lost tissue the nipples will die
and you've got this gnarled up crap crab
claws appearance where there's nothing
there what are you going to do you go to
the botched doctor try to fix that so
that's the most common complication so
for that reason that's the most common
fix-it surgery okay but my favorite
i like i like doing
i like doing really difficult stuff that
doesn't necessarily have breast implants
associated with because i can nail
breast implants and
fix it and it's perfect and they love me
and they're happy and then three months
later the body went now [ __ ] you and it
just put scar tissue around and said i
don't like this and you go ah so even
though technically i nailed it got it to
heal right
the body said no i don't like it and put
scar tissue around it okay
you said the nipple will die what does
that mean okay so
when you take a breast apart
right you have to naturally when you do
any surgery you cut blood supply
by the very nature of making an incision
when plastic surgery we lift tissue off
as you lift it off you're cutting more
and more blood supply as they've had
more and more surgery there's more more
scarring within the tissue so there's
naturally less left feet less fuel going
to the nipple right well if you cut too
much skin here and too much skin on the
side and you lift it out too much and
you put two you take too big of an
implant put it undermining the
circulation that's exactly right you're
choking off the fuel supply the oxygen
the arterial blood flow to the nipple
and so that's gonna do nerve damage not
nerve damage it's vascular damage so
nerves is for sensation so the vascular
dents so it starts to turn
blue and then black and oh it dies
wow and so what you want to do is you
know it's a game we play with the
tissues this tissue has been completely
damaged and trashed how much more
trauma can i subject it to before i
bugger it before it now doesn't have
enough blood supply to stay alive and
i'll give you an example so
there's a case these are on boxes i have
these cases in my real practice too not
that i did
where a doctor will go to mexico or go
to some guy what's weird in plastic
surgery any doctor can do plastic
surgery legally in this country a
radiologist can decide to take a weekend
course and call himself a cosmetic
surgeon on monday
not in mexico no in mexico too okay but
mexico can be a street vendor
it's true
but it's legal if you how'd you like a
radiologist or rheumatologist or a
cardiologist to do cosmetic surgery
right but they still do it okay so
in general for example if you take
someone's abdomen to do a tummy tuck you
make an incision you lift it up tighten
the muscles and you pull the excess down
and cut it off
if you also do liposuction to that
tissue that remains and beat it up too
much the whole thing can die
so i've had cases for mexico from
arizona from all over the country where
they do too much liposuction and the
whole thing the next morning is turning
blue and then it turns black and the
entire abdominal wall
dies
can you go back
can you go back and fix it no i mean can
i can it go back to life throwback no
well okay so if you identify that that's
happening and you and it's from a
reversible cause
right you can maybe help it and keep it
alive but most of the time when you've
beaten it up too much that's not a
reversible cause if you put a breast
implant in that's too big and it's
squeezing off the blood supply nipple
you go oh it's dying in the first 24
hours you take the implant out let it
breathe
you can you can okay reverse it aloud
and then put a smaller implant later but
in most of the tissue once it starts to
die
you can't salvage it so that's that's
what i do like you're it's missing parts
surgery so
so in the case where the abdominal wall
dies
uh i mean there's no bringing that back
to life you're gonna have to to remove
that
it you remove the dead tissue and then
it scars in and you maybe do a skin
graft or whatever it's done to get a
closed wound to get biological control
of the wound so now you have this
massively scarred up contracted disaster
situation that or it just it just
scarred up and closed on itself but now
it looks terrible so what do you do for
that i mean we've i'm trying to imagine
too when you say abdominal wall i'm
thinking about muscle no not the muscle
doesn't die you can't kill the muscle
it's got the blood supply comes from too
deep it's the skin okay so the skin and
uh
when it closes on its own i'm picturing
that it's uh it's contracted it's so
tight that you can't sit up and stand up
straighter you can't sit up you're in
chronic pain it's pulling the nerves
giving you neuralgias it's a disaster so
you're gonna have to open that up and
then add in
it's like uh is that that's grafting no
well yeah you don't you see you don't
necessarily want to graft because it'll
look terrible so you try to bring in
like tissue tissue that looks that's a
so you try to you have this expression
that for example you uh you know we
steal from peter to pay paul if
peter can afford it is the expression
wow i love that so
you know if it's an abdomen sometimes
i'll rotate up a piece of tissue from
the leg that's very close and undermine
it here and recreate it that way or you
can put tissue expanders in sometimes
how's that not a uh a graft
that's that's not a skin graft a skin
graft is you you know you basically mow
a piece of skin off right right
that you put on here looks terrible
i've got i've got some right here is
that a skin yeah you see how that little
mesh
right
where
that that means that that
cadavers flesh became my flesh it's a
one area isn't that cool was that a burn
it was burns yeah fifteen percent of my
body i had uh the flesh from seven
different dead people grafted on and
that one little patch became me well how
did you get burned uh i laid in rocket
engine fuel and this guy set me on fire
oh yes
burns are the worst like i i i ended up
on a little bit of a tour of burn units
yeah and heard repeatedly that people
who have been
either
uh shot or stabbed or both
will always tell you that burns hurt the
most they do burns so i did a full
general surgery training after med
school i went to ucla med school and i
did seven years of general surgery
training where you're like the trauma
doctor and i was chief resident trauma
and then i went on to plastic surgery
when you do burns and plastic surgery
you spend a lot of time in a burn unit
so i spent a year in a burn unit doing
burn surgery and it is the worst injury
of all absolutely and you know what you
die of when you have a massive burn all
over your body dehydration that's right
because the because the water's going to
try to cool down the burn that's what a
blister is well no the main function of
skin is to hold water in your body so
when you burn a large percentage of your
body surface area that's what we call
bsa body surface area
you can't keep watering and you die
from hypovolemia you die from
dehydration so that's why you got to get
these things covered
and grafted as fast as possible
otherwise people just sweat to death not
really
i read an article in brazil they use uh
tilapia skin to do skin grafts or some
places do pig skin or human skin what's
the difference and why would you it's
about the immune system okay so
you you if it's if it's a xenograft
which is an
a non-human skin
your body will immediately reject it so
it's a temporary thing but the body is
going to slowly eat it up anyway so if
like someone's really burned but they're
unstable you don't want to do the final
human skin grafting you
you can put pig skin on but you could
you have to take it off it's essentially
a band-aid it's a band-aid now cadaver
skin
um the best skin is your own skin right
so you take a skin graft from one part
of your body that's normally what you
get is your own skin because cadaver
skin is not the greatest either you
could do it for very small areas but for
big areas you got to use your own skin
well i i i got away with it then because
i had pretty large areas yeah 15 is a
lot i mean did they admit you put ivs in
you took them five days to go in i
didn't go and he was just having a
picture he's facing his hotel room like
dude we gotta go i was just toughing it
out oh boy do i have pictures yeah
because
that's he looked like e.t he had a big
bulb on the end of his finger oh yeah
the blisters
i mean
i had bonafide bags of uh of skin i
don't even know what the medical term is
what are your bags like
yeah [ __ ]
yeah but they admitted you for this
right they they did well i waited for
five days and then they didn't get
infected how did you deal with that pain
it was the worst pain i've ever
experienced and each day the pain got
worse and worse by five days i couldn't
handle it anymore i tapped out and i
went to the hospital and at the hospital
they said you need emergency surgery yep
right away um and they asked me when was
the last time i'd eaten and i had just
eaten
i went in there saying that i wouldn't
have any painkillers because i'm a sober
guy right and um oh yeah and then they
said uh well because you just ate we
can't we can't operate on you for
another eight hours right and i said
okay
give me something yeah give me something
and my my arms were so burned they put
it into my neck they put in the jugular
yeah yeah and ij yeah that's where we do
it sometimes patients were so burned in
my general surgery training that you'd
put it right you put the needle right
through
the burn into the big vein wow it's all
about fluid resuscitation is that the
aorta no it's a vein aorta is the main
artery you don't want to put anything on
that yeah you said that that uh
early in your practice you were working
in a burn unit but was that a like um
doing plastic surgery after the the the
burns had healed yeah so when you're in
when you're a general surgeon you deal
with acute burns right like you go to a
burn unit it's all a bunch of general
surgeons they cut out the dead tissue
but plastic surgery is focused on burn
reconstruction so if someone has a burn
and they have you know uh a web here
or a contracture you can't lift your arm
help us understand what a web is so if
you get a burn from here to here it
shortens the skin and gives you a
website
so you can't can't extend your neck at
all right right that's right they told
me i had to be really careful as i
healed to move that's the key thing
contracture it'll heal in one yeah so
you do we have all these fancy
techniques to lengthen scars
or so that you can move have normal
range of motion or we yeah or when when
you lengthen a scar
god that's fascinating do you have to
uh plug in each strip
so like so the general principle behind
lengthening a scar is you have to make
incisions
outside of the scar
to bring tissue that's normal into it to
lengthen it so for example if you have a
band a scar contracture band here so you
can't you'd make a cut here and you'd
make a cut here it's called a z plasti
and you would elevate up tissue here
elevated tissue here and then transpose
it which would lengthen the whole thing
and that's how you get relief but you
have to make additional geometry
wow it's very trippy yeah yeah cool so i
mean a lot of what i do now obviously is
just
total disaster surgery but people ever
uh try to just throw more money at you
to keep you going to to keep improving
the
that but that's how they got in trouble
to begin with what i what i run into now
is they i i say look just because i'm on
a tv show and i crack a few jokes and i
mean i do this
impossible surgery doesn't mean you
won't have a complication doesn't mean
you're gonna
have you're gonna have perfect breasts
or perfect face or whatever or perfect
stuff stomach so i will get them it'll
be a lot of times i'll get
an a minus
they want to be
what they were promised with their first
surgery which they wanted to be
right perfect i said don't use the p
word with me how about and i can't tell
how many times in the last seven to ten
years patients i'll say don't you think
it's beautiful they go oh no it's
beautiful it's not it's just not what i
want i go whoa whoa
it should be it's beautiful period or
it's beautiful period thank you you're
the best
especially since these people by
definition are like the most
self-conscious insecure
vain like you've got this heightened
things so so of course yeah they you
have to be very careful particularly the
ones we bring on the tv show to make
sure that they have realistic
expectations you know we we try to
undersell them and over deliver
everybody tries to do that but we really
try to do that but they
when when when it goes in one ear out
the other i you're the botch doctor
you're on tv you've got special powers
and we go whoa i do not have special
powers if the risk isn't too high see
the problem is
you can bugger them going from an 83 to
a 93. for sure it's like playing
blackjack it really is yeah yeah
it really is so i want to walk away
really careful
and i have in my real practice have had
a couple patients where
it's an 89 improvement they started out
as a it was a disaster and it actually
looks good it looks good but they don't
want it looks good they want it to be
it's awesome and i go listen
this next one we could run into
statistics we could run into
data here i could
i could have a problem and
when that happens then they get pissed
have you ever said
used a blackjack analogy
no but i might start doing that right
hey you're sitting here
where's that when you want 21 on
blackjack yeah right yeah you're sitting
here 20. you're sitting here with like
18.
you're asking for him you're asking me
to give you a hit yeah yeah now you know
we obviously have them sign these forms
right at the end of the day they just
sign them i say read these you know and
if you ever watch bach you know we
really warn people yeah sure i mean
that's what what heightens the drama of
the show it does is that that there's
this inherent risk of catastrophic
failure well were you about to ask me a
question yeah but uh if you're finished
well so there was an episode of botch
where this woman had had all this you
ever heard of these plump pumping
parties candidly i had not heard about
these pumping parties but god are they
fascinating what i have heard about that
pumps is my heart and i know all about
how it pumps because i wear a woop
fitness band it's the single most
sophisticated fitness tracking device on
earth period and now it's completely
waterproof you just take your waterproof
charger you slide it right on top so the
band never comes off
and man this thing is going to make you
healthier happier it's going to make you
sleep better because you're going to
find out what's going on with your body
at all times with the killer whoop app
it's synced up to your phone
you're gonna find out so much awesome
stuff like now it's even got your blood
oxygen on there it's got like a little
haptic
uh dynamic which can buzz your wrist
when you've reached your optimum amount
of sleep i'm telling you what are they
going to come up with next it tells you
about your heart rate variability which
is a very important metric
all stages of sleep recovery how many
calories you're burning
i'm telling you i love my whoop band and
this company whoop loves you the
listeners of the wild ride podcast so
much they're giving you 15
off at checkout if you go to woop.com
and use the promo code stevo
jump on this deal because it is epic it
is whoop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot-com
and you use the promo code stevo for 15
off at checkout man love whoop
and thank you now let's get back to it
they'll go to a hotel they'll have
caulking materials from an unlicensed
person injecting their face rather than
pay for
or or non-sterile silicone and it causes
like masses and inflammatory disasters
there's one on botch where she was
turned down by every doctor for the last
10 years and she looked like the
elephant man her name's raji i mean i
can show you a picture i'll bring up a
picture okay
mass is everywhere with inflammatory
granulomas and she came on botch and
we she came on and we turned her down
because we turned down
a third of the patients on botch i mean
gotta figure that if uh if everybody
else is turning her down what's the
likelihood that you're gonna go and put
a big television spotlight on it that
not only that if everyone else turned
her down a bunch of board-certified
plastic surgeons turned turner down and
you take her to the or and you make it
worse the hubris i mean
it's basically you knew that 10 other
doctors turned down right
why did you do that that's almost sounds
like malpractice you're getting over
into the you're doing experimentation so
this woman comes on
season three
with concrete in her face
concrete masses i mean
unbelievable just home depot [ __ ] like
home depot [ __ ] literally caulking
material the uh
the person who did it end up going to
jail for murder oh my god injected a
couple of people in their butt it went
up to their lungs and killed them so she
was yeah the madam they called her so
she comes in and then i thought to
myself
gosh she was really walking around i
thought about it for about six months
nine months the next season came out i
thought and i woke up one morning at
four o'clock and i had an epiphany about
i thought i know how to fix her
don't go in there and try to because it
was so close to the surface even if you
could remove it from the inside you're
going to devascularize the skin it's all
going to die and now her face is going
to be
necrotic gangrenous like a zombie
so i thought wait a minute i'm not
thinking about this right what if i just
took
the part off from the inside that was
causing the mass and left
the part
right next to the skin intact keeping
the blood supply intact as long as you
can't see it
so i'm trying to shave it down like what
if i
uh take off the bottom half take off the
bottom half leave the concrete in but
just get it further away from the
surface exactly and just get it so you
can't see the because if you feel your
skull it's super irregular
right i mean there's lumps and bumps all
over it but just as long as it looks
smooth you don't care that you can feel
your zygomatic arch and the way it
inserts into the max maxillary area you
know who cares just as long as it looks
okay so is that a function of pulling
the cement underneath like muscle tissue
so you have to go in there and lift it
up so now it's attached to the skin and
here's the mass right here
well rather than trying to pull this
whole thing out i took an orthopedic saw
and i went
cut off this part so it sat flat
and i did it all over her face
and
for a year and a half the big concern is
when you do that you're just going to
piss off the body and the immune system
the body will go [ __ ] you and just start
forming more inflammatory tissue for a
year and a half
she looked amazing i have pictures it's
on the it's on the internet
and then she came back and some of them
grew back i took her back again and took
more off and now it's been six years
perfect wow
so that was my epiphany but at the end
of the day had that gone badly
she could have said you know all these
other doctors said my chance of a
complication is 100
and you promised me you know it's on tv
so no one's gonna it's all right
evidence and proof that i didn't over
promise right right but it worked and
since then
i've had patients flying from all over
the world i've done that
wow
it's a little bit like sweeping the
cement under it's exactly what it is
it's exactly
so being on botched also forced you to
and i hate to use this word too loosely
but invent procedures because you don't
really want inventors it sounds like
again right you're experimenting on
patients but you have to be creative but
you have to be creative using
fundamental surgical principles then it
makes sense then it'll hold up in a
courtroom yeah yeah so sure um i had a
woman who very thin woman who had
gigantic breast implants put in her
buttock areas butt implants
and it's like what and it's it caused so
much pain and hardness and it was
compressing her sciatic nerve she
couldn't live like that so she had to
have them taken out it got to the point
where she couldn't even walk very
attractive woman
really perfect body but had the big
giant implants in her butt compressing
the nerve the problem is if you take
them out the buttock skin is just going
to sit here right like you know you're
like you've had triplets or something
and so
what do you do for that
well that's got to be the most common
question because when people are getting
breast reductions or getting implants
removed like breast implants removed
you've naturally got all this saggy skin
like the person's just lost 100 pounds
it's true but you still have breast
tissue remember there's a girl who and
the implant had atrophied her antibiotic
tissue she had by compression and just
gone and you have
you have basic
structural changes you can make that
make sense the buttock has its own
natural architecture and if you mess
with its architecture too much
see the face
your your face is defined by your bones
more than your skin beauty is in the
bones what are the bones of the buttock
there is none right and there's no
breath there's no real tissue in the
buttock when it's been destroyed by
previous implants so i thought how do i
give her volume without using implants
because she wasn't going to tolerate
implants anymore so what i did was i
invented a procedure where i took
her
um
her tissue
her love handle that's exactly right
it's the words i was looking for her
love handle tissue just as long as you
leave a portion of it intact where a
main artery is going in it's got a fuel
supply and i rotated it down
into
the buttock lifted the buttock skin over
it on both sides and removed the excess
skin and went
come on now that is a procedure that
exists for reconstructing horrible
cancer deformities where you'd flip it
over on the front but it's never been
flipped
as a cosmetic procedure in the buttock
and now it's like a thing i routinely do
wow
it's one of the most common things i do
someone wants more body protection i
throw it in you know because you can't
inject free you've heard of brazilian
butt lifts that's like bbl bbl you've
heard you know what a bbl is you do
liposuction
and you inject it into the buttock
to give people bigger buttocks i mean oh
so that's like a production like a
cellulite transplant it's like a fat
transplant it is it's a pure fat
transplant okay
so the problem with that is if you get
those fatty particles a little too deep
into the buttock
there are very short blood vessels in
the bottom of the bug that connect right
to the inferior vena cava the main blood
vessel that leads back to the right side
of your heart that goes to your lungs
you inject fat
into those short little gluteal vessels
it gets into the main inferior vena cave
it goes to your lungs
dead on the table or maybe within a
couple days
it's the most fatal procedure in plastic
surgery at bbo in fact it's so fatal
that they gathered an international task
force to try to get doctors to stop
doing it i stopped doing but it's still
super common so if you can rotate
someone's love handles instead that
doesn't have the same risk it can't get
into the blood vessels
it works but you know you gotta
it's not something you really want to
teach other plastic surgeons yeah i was
gonna say are other people now doing
your surgery um no they're still terry
foldbackers right some kind of right the
terry butt lifts the terry
yeah
the terry transformer because i picture
it like a transformer going from a car
into a robot well it's interesting in
medicine you used to be able to name
procedures after the doctor who invented
them and then that became a big no-no so
i lost interest once you can't name it
after the bro butt augmentation that's
correct no i'm kidding um
you know they still are injecting fat
they're just trying to keep it more
superficial but when you hear of eight
people dying in a month in florida it's
from that operation wow
dangerous what is the uh like the
dysphoria or is it some kind of a
condition where
somebody just keeps getting lip
injection and they think it looks pretty
i think you're looking for dysmorphia no
no but like that's right but they look
in the mirror they think it looks
beautiful but to everybody else it's so
[ __ ] big yeah like do they not see
how big it is or are they seeing
something different than we're seeing
it's bdd body dysmorphic disorder bdd
it's where you what you see is so out of
proportion to what the normal person
sees right like for example someone will
have a little bump on their nose oh my
god and then you take it down they still
see it and they'll get another surgeon
that by the way if a bot
every once in a while so the way it
works on bots
is they'll send us the pictures and at
this stage we go i can fix it i can fix
it i can fix it you know bring them in
and you bring them in immediately you're
looking at going okay are you a psycho
you have to it's the binary psychonaut
psycho test and if they immediately you
can tell a psycho right you know it gets
your red flags it's in the eyes it's in
the eye you go okay no matter what even
though this is the coolest case and i
want to do this on tv
you're too much of a sleeper psychos
by the way
there are sleeper cycles and that's the
ones that we're super afraid of right
because
girlfriends right
right
um so they'll charm you the sleeper
cycles their sociopaths sometime you're
they'll white knight you oh my gosh
you're the best oh i'm so take pictures
with me
no i know i know and even you aren't you
know fool proof and then afterwards oh
my god this is a disaster you have to be
really careful the way you evaluate the
sleeper psycho so sometimes on bots they
come and you go i want to do this so bad
the producers will say you should i go
i'm sure and we've been doing bots with
the same producers for so long
they they're the first ones that hear
about i'm unhappy so if i say their
psycho they go yeah get by next and now
you know we have 15 000 people applying
to be unboxed all over the world so it's
really easy i'm curious like for you
what's the incentive to do the show does
it just did it raise your profile
it's like asking a a tattoo artist why
they would want a reality tv show about
their tattoo practice because once the
show comes out they've got a waiting
list of like four years yeah is it just
so much simple is that so
yeah when you're a doctor see i did a tv
show called the swan do you remember
this i remember i was the doctor of that
show wow i totally remember that that
show put me on the map and got me i was
only four years out of my training when
i did it and so it got me the most
mature practice i was booked for five
years after that show so i got really
good because it's all experiential
it's like what you do you get good at
what you do all the time right you can't
have anybody do this stuff right so the
more you do it like sports the better
you get at it so i got really good
really fast not because i'm so talented
all my training was the best in the
world at ucla but
if the if this guy's doing a hundred
plastic surgery cases a year and i'm
doing 820
in five years it's why kobe would get to
the gym before the other guys and would
be the last lead you do 20 000 shots
that day you're better you're just
better yeah yeah so
i got really good really fast but when
it came to botched i thought doing a tv
show is fun
you know
um doing challenging plastic surgery is
really fun the question is
why would i want to do it anymore
i'm not going to get any more famous
than i am you either know who i am or
you don't and if you don't what color is
it the rock that you've been living
under no i'm kidding
that was good
that's great
no um
but at this point my wife said to me
there she goes
why do you want to keep doing botch i
said cause
it's like being a fighter pilot you know
it's like you want to fly it's it's just
hair on fire and it's cool and i'm
really into it
and i love it and i'm good at it and at
the end of the day
surgeons want to operate that's what
we're born for sure i just got back from
a vacation in hawaii and i
i
consider it
the most miserable experience i've had
thus far this year why because ford uh
yeah or it takes me about 10 minutes to
get completely bored if i'm not doing
something and i got to believe that
that's got it okay so we haven't been
doing the pandemic really slowed us down
they weren't sure whether they were
going to bring that's back because they
had 178 episodes that's like enough to
go into syndication or whatever their
version of that on cable tv is so
they're going ah and then so we didn't
we haven't done botch for like nine
months usually we go we do it we go
start rip right into production again
okay
so i was normally i do botched
all day on wednesdays we filmed the
consults and then half day on tuesday we
do the botched surgery
and so i said you know what
that's when you're in production but
you're not in production all the time
exactly but but normally weren't out of
production very long but we've been out
of production for nine months and so i
said well maybe i just won't work on
wednesdays anymore
you know it wouldn't be nice because i
worked my ass off for a while i was
operating seven days a week there was no
difference between sunday and monday for
me so i started not working on
wednesdays and then i'm sitting around
going
and i call my office to go maybe book
one case wednesday morning and they go
okay okay my wife goes you're doing a
quesadilla yeah i'm just gonna do one
case wednesday morning and then all of a
sudden i'm going
you know maybe just book another short
case after that sounds like me with my
touring agent right you wanna you wanna
i like i you know and and it's hair on
fire man i love operating plus what am i
gonna do with these skills and we have
this expression in in surgery where
if i don't operate
for two weeks
i'll notice the difference if i don't
operate for three weeks you'll notice
the difference
you know what i'm saying you need it's
like playing tennis or football you need
to be operating all the time you can't
take too much time off and your volume
can't be low even at this advanced stage
of my life in my career i need to be
i need to be unconscious operating where
i'm going okay i'm going to go over
there and you know it's like driving you
how did you get there you didn't realize
oh i've been driving incredible
unconscious we just uh spoke with the
champion
uh ufc fighter okay who who was a champ
a simultaneous champion in two different
weight divisions not much not connor not
conor okay uh that was daniel cormier oh
awesome and uh and he said that uh i was
saying i asked him how satisfying it is
to
while commentating say oh this person
this fighter needs to roll over on this
hip
and then exactly what you said is
exactly what happens is it's so
satisfying and he said
uh yes it is but
since i've stopped fighting those
times are fewer because i'm not the
further you get away from fighting the
less you can see
exactly and so it's it's really
important to be operating if you want to
do difficult surgery to be operating all
the time doing difficult surgery you
know it's funny so
my wife if you're interested i'll show
you my house my what we do we build
houses right i mean occasionally and so
i built this house in pelican crest
quick story from the ground up beautiful
house and we sold it and then buying
this lot and building it
um
is this in the same neighborhood that
kobe lived that that was pelican crest
he didn't live in crystal we're in
crystal cove he lived in pelican that's
the same neighborhood yeah he lived
right around yes one of the thrills i
had is one time buddy for my birthday
bought me
seat set on the floor
at the laker game and it was like one of
his last games and i'd seen him around
he knows who i am and we'd see each
other disneyland we sort of waved to
each other he comes up to me goes hey
man how you doing in front of my friends
like oh yeah kobe bryant
oh man
anyway so i get a call from a friend of
mine he goes hey isn't this your old
house in pelican crest i go yeah
who's there and i know my buddy does the
clothes for conor mcgregor okay and he
goes
is connor renting that house while he's
training for his fight against whoever
he lost to oh oh uh dusty
no khabib uh i can't remember that
that's been a few years yeah and so
yeah maybe it was yeah anyway and i i
said he goes yeah i really can't talk
about because conor had you know
like the secret service there basically
yeah
so then saturday he calls me up and he
goes
hey what are you doing right now i go i
just got home from work i was wearing
exactly what i'm wearing now and he goes
come over to your old house i'm thinking
why he goes just come over i drive over
it's two minutes away and i open the
door it's my old house and it wasn't
hadn't changed that much and conor
mcgregor is there with a foot injury
wow so he had a bunch of skin
pull off on the mat i took him to my
surgery center i obviously worked on it
was very cool that that wasn't the the
serious break that he got no no that was
that wasn't that that one
before that was that right that was with
justin right yeah so that was the fight
before that right right yeah um
okay so i i've been dying to ask you
this yep uh what can you tell me about
men
getting
breast implants
so it's v you mean that when they're
transitioning or just as a goo
just
because because like i got the whole
question
i'm at a point with um all of my crazy
antics that the bar is so high i'm
actually planning for my next tour
because i do multimedia comedy and i
tell the stories about these crazy
things and i screen the footage in the
theater right and for my next tour i've
decided that it's called stevo's gone
too far to her and and i'm just trying
to i'm just trying to be so crazy and
one of my ideas is to get rest about to
get breast implants so
that we had we had a person on botched
you can see it on youtube who did that
they lost a bet
okay i mean this was ages ago i saw i
think he saw it
and
he thought it was so interesting and so
he kept it for like over ten years he
did
and so the if you're gonna if you must
if you're gonna do it put them in and
then take them out
relatively short okay because that's
exactly what i'm thinking before i go on
the tour i want to restore everything
back to uh yeah if you do if it isn't in
for too long and doesn't stretch your
skin for because last thing you want to
do is have to have them removed and a
bunch of scars put on your chest right
because that like like secretly candidly
like one of my main reasons i was so
excited to talk to you was to ask about
this yeah and what the uh
because it just seems like it's got
botched written all over it does to have
um if i get the breast implants removed
and then i've got all this loose skin
yeah and is that something that you can
clean up yes but i but what i'm telling
you you're not going to keep them in for
a year right i think closer to six
months
if you don't maybe as little as three
okay if you don't go too big
what's too big yeah big can i see some
double d's on them do you i want to go
as big as i can show me your chest
now
yeah
i've i've developed dimples under my man
boobs and that's why oh you have some
loose skin well the problem is you're a
little stretched if you go too big how
big is too big
if you go to a d
all right and you keep these in for
a relative term
well in general you we all know what a b
cup is it's like pornography it's hard
to define but you know when you see it
so a b cup is like you know a champlain
glass right a c cup you start to get
into sort of an orange and there can be
a small c mid c full c we all know
you and i have an understanding this is
d right and this is double d okay okay
you have enough room you could probably
do d or double d you shoot that and you
keep it in for six months
that's getting maybe past the point
where your skin will retract okay so you
might want to do a c cup but then get
them out after three to six months and
you won't have to have a skin reducing
procedure and bunch of scars but scars
if that's your worst case scenario
that's not that bad
i'm all ready
i was already just mortified that i took
off my shirt
on camera just now like taking off my
shirt and feeling good about it is part
of my past and so if i have scars
from uh you don't care i mean i don't
know that well i mean and your nipple
falling off i don't necessarily want to
have uh
have scars i i take that back but um but
if you do this would you do me a huge
favor you don't have to say yes or no
right now because i'm sure the answer is
probably no
if you put in breast implants will you
please come on botched
and show us please
absolutely absolutely not know if
anything
my wheels are turning about how we can
get into business together to make this
happen where
we're botched and you know like i'll
tell you how
i can't put them in
okay because you're doing this you're
doing as a goof but you can get any
doctor to put them in i could probably
turn you onto a doctor to put them to
put them in for free i'm sure i could
right
but i'll take them out that's exactly
what i want to do sure
having his implants taken out come on
perfect yeah i mean dude like like uh
secretly that was like my highest goal
oh
done oh dude i love it okay
the boobs to me are so funny there's
there's so many different fun ways like
for example
i recently bought a smart car for the
purpose
of crashing it into a brick wall to make
sure that the airbags work okay right
it's called the it's called the airbag
test okay but if you follow me after i
get my boob job i want to crash the car
into a wall to do a fun bag test a fun
bag test
well they won't get injured the breast
implants are incredibly tough no we uh
paul and i have dropped them we ran it
over with his ferrari
dude dude you're my favorite
yeah you're my like dude
like
i knew it was going to be the most
fascinating conversation yeah thank you
we we ran it by the way when i told when
when blythe first asked me i said are
you kidding me i absolutely want to meet
him and talk to him i knew this would be
incredibly fun but we dropped it from a
building in beverly hills we ran over
with a ferrari i'd be less concerned
about the implant itself than the actual
like a tissue
yeah so that by the way
patients will always say what happens if
i get into a car accident and the
implant ruptures i say if you get into a
car accident that's significantly
traumatic enough to rupture implant
worry about the structures underneath
your implant like cardiac damage or
pulmonary damage or even just even just
the the the tissue the skin around no i
mean i've seen a million not a million a
lot of car accidents with breast
implants and
they it's really
you know you worry about the cardiac
contusion the rib fractures right yeah
it's not going to do much so so we're
going we're going d we're getting them
out within three months what if you had
like francis and ganu punch one and try
to break it by the way wow
you can try to punch your tip right off
what you could do
you could have a doctor i can't believe
i'm telling you
if only we had cold opens on podcasts
all right but you could have a
saline there's two kind of implants
right there they're all silicone shells
say salt water and salt which is saline
and then silicone on the inside right
you could have a saline implant
massively overfilled so it wouldn't
require
impossible amounts of trauma to get it
to rupture you could have that ufc
fighter that big giant guy smash your
chest with an with his fist in an
over-filled saline implant that would
probably if he did it hard enough
that would probably rupture you'd have
to go straight to the doctor right no i
mean you could have a ruptured implant
you know you want to get it out
soon enough if he's got the saline in
there yeah
if you like drilled a hole or some or
punctured it would it just like
like water would just the water would
just come out like can you just like
puncture it and just squeeze the water
out no because you know his tissue
thickness is like this right so it's
it's like say it's two centimeters it's
three quarters of an inch thick right
until you get to the implant you stab
through it you pull the for example a
knife out
immediately the tissue collapses on
itself okay so it would rupture because
i've seen stab wounds it would rupture
on the inside which is
okay but it would not it would not come
out but if you stabbed it with a straw
like a juice box but you're never
getting through the skin
ah oh and you me and you kept it if
there's a metal straw you stuck it in
you could drink it out right right
on botched by the way yeah we've had
patients who have such giant implants
that are starting to wear through the
skin that if we just took them out and
the skin's so thin has such poor blood
supply that if we put a smaller implant
cut all that skin off the skin would die
it needs to thicken up so what i've done
is you take an iv yeah and you put it in
there and you drain it out
let it contract down scar tissue forms
around it then it's safe to do it you
know the tissue but no you can't i'm
just thinking out loud okay
i uh
this is a complete uh change of topic
and and we'll wrap it up here soon but i
think anybody in the medical field has
heard stories about people coming into
the er where they've put something up
their butt yes and they can't get it out
we had a drawer
you had a drawer we had a drawer when i
was at the county hospital when i was in
general surgery where it was the drawer
of stuff we pulled out of people's butts
it was a legendary joke yeah
somebody had a drawer up there but no a
drawer you pulled out and it was like it
was filled with it's like candlesticks
and vibrators and
like partially deep i've heard about a
squirrel or something like an entire
squirrel a squirrel wouldn't make the
drawer we had those would make jerks you
know they'd start to smell yeah
they're dead you could put it in a a
case of formaldehyde yeah
so i'll tell you a quick story if you
want yeah general surgery my best
stories are from general surgery today
we don't have another hour i could tell
you one of them i mean dude
we're approaching longer than uh then
we've gone but dude i'm fascinated and
i'll tell you two quick stories see if
you like them one is i had this patient
come in i'm an intern in general surgery
i've been up all night for days you know
i'm tired as hell and
i walk in and see this guy sitting there
and i go
uh the er said hey we've got a consult
for you so i come down it's two o'clock
in the morning and i say the guy i go
what's going he goes no i can't
go to the bathroom i go what do you mean
he goes i'm really constipated and i go
okay so how long have you been
constipated for oh about 12 hours ago
well some people get constipated for 12.
he goes no i can't i can't i go i try to
get he won't tell me what's going on all
of a sudden you hear
there this go i'm thinking
well tell me and he wouldn't and so
finally i look up there and i look up
his butt i put the proctoscope in there
the endoscope and sure enough
on the end of this vibrator was like a
clown's head and they'd go whoa he's
like this big clown he's got this clown
vibrator stuck up his butt
so we had to take him to the operating
room
and we told him hey we'll put you under
anesthesia we'll try to relax your
sphincter enough to pull it out but if
we can't
we got to open you up
you open it up from the front you open
it for and you know go down to the colon
and make an incision the colon and pull
it out there you'd rather not do that
because that's big time surgery why
would it get stuck i mean wouldn't it
come out or so
what happens is you put a vibrator up
there or some object up there
and there's all these sphincteric
muscles o-rings the o-rings they
collapse around it and
and and you can and it's also it moves
up there you can't get it out with your
hand you can't get it dilated if you try
in the or when he's under anesthesia to
dilate it you know and and reach up and
get it but once it starts to get up
towards
the splenic flexure of the large
intestine you know way up there the only
place to get it out is shh
and open up the intestine and pull it
out that way chinese finger trap yeah
they just come out you have like a plug
see that keeps it at the shrinker level
yeah that's the key never go all the way
in okay quick story general surgery i
think is so up your alley maybe so
i'm chief resident these two brothers
each other
okay not in the hospital they come in
they come in we got a trauma run you
know where beepers go off trump trauma
so we come down and both brothers in the
same way both brothers and sami are in
the two bed next to each other because
it's the red blanket room where you know
where they're gonna bleed are they both
stabbed in different places so one
brother
stabs his chubbier brother like 15 times
in the abdomen
and then
the chubbier brother stabs the skinnier
one one time
right here on the side of the chest okay
so they bring them in
uh up in the upper chest kidneys in the
in the back of the abdomen okay so the
upper chest all right so
the skinny brother with a single stab
wound in the chest seemed fine so we put
him
this bed his brother who he stabbed 15
times obviously the entire trauma team
is focusing on him well as chief
resident gets to sort of stand back you
get to make the big decisions you know
while everybody's gathering around these
people so i'm talking to the skinny
brother with the single stab when well
we're all focusing on the guy putting
ivs putting folies in getting ready for
the operating room
and i say how you doing man he goes i
don't know
i'm thir they're going [ __ ] yeah if i
get there screaming at each other i go
how you feeling he goes i'm thirsty
yeah i said you're thirsty he goes yeah
i'm really thirsty doc
that when someone says to you they're
thirsty they're about to die
wow after a trauma why because all the
things go on there they've lost so much
blood or their hearts having trouble
there's some weird feedback thing in the
brain thirsty is a
pre-morbid mortal event okay super
thirsty and i go i go you're thirsty he
goes yeah i look up and his pulse rate's
starting to slowly go up his vital signs
have been stable single no big deal stab
wound here and also i mean you're
talking about a stab wound to the chest
right but but he was fine okay all right
so
i
slowly pull
the
thoracotomy tray we have these trays
that are prepared for emergency
operations sometimes you have to do in
the er and i slowly start to open it and
there all my whole team is gathered
around the kid with the multiple stab
wounds of course
and all of a sudden he goes
out
and you see
he flatlines like whoa oh let's go so he
obviously had a stab wound
to his heart
that was slowly bleeding in there's a
sack around the heart called the
pericardial sac
that had a hole in it but it wasn't
blood wasn't coming out right so it
slowly was oozing and once it got to the
point where there was enough blood
around the heart in this pericardial sac
it couldn't pump anymore and he
basically died
so what i did was
i sprayed them with betadine
i took what's betadine betadine is a
disinfectant right spray them with
betadine open up the throat
right here the entire chest yeah okay i
gotta get something to clean them you
know i don't want to get septic
afterwards and
i open up the thoracotomy tray
thoracotomy means open up the chest tray
and i take a big scalpel and i go like
this between the fourth and fifth rib i
just flame open right there
pull out the rib spreaders put the rib
sprayers and go oh [ __ ] it goes shh
like this
and there's his heart
with the para cuddle sack filled with
blood i cut the parakoto sec the blood
goes everywhere and he's got one single
stab wound to the heart but it's
bleeding like stink so i put my finger
on there and we have these special
suture materials that has these little
what are called pledges like q-tips so
it doesn't tear through the muscle
because it's a muscle anyway i step one
stitch in one stitch back and i sew it
down and all of a sudden boom boom boom
boom
and get his vitals back
and then take him in the operating room
wash him out
that was it
and so he went from dead to totally
alive and then about 12 days later from
when he flatlined to when the
hearts beating again what was that i had
i had i had the pericardial sac open to
take the pressure off in about
45 seconds wow dead
to alive to life in prison no
that's a good point
and so well what's weird is so
i sort of forgot about him he was in the
icu the interns and junior residents are
taking care of them and then like ten
days later i hear this hey doc it's like
seven in the morning and we're about to
go to breakfast before we start the day
surgeries and stuff and i go like this i
go i go he goes hey dude bro doc duck
duck i go there he goes like this he
looks and it's the guy he's walking out
he's being discharged and he goes like
this he goes thanks man
what the [ __ ] and i go
my pleasure
and so that was like one of the most
radical moments in my general surgery
residency where i opened a guy's chest
in the er sewed up a single
knife wound to his heart saved him and
he walked out i mean just to open his
ribs like that that's like a imagine
what that looks like
[Applause]
what you call the the uh
rip spreader rib spreaders
exactly what you would look like it's
this tool
it has these things you gotta cut
between the ribs you put it in and then
it's got this little turning thing and
it goes
and it's not it's a carjack
exactly yeah and it just goes
and also there's this heart
and you're doing it like frenetically
fast i'm going
and i remember the weirdest thing i
remember is i was present while i was
doing it
time for anesthesia in that situation
the guy is unconscious anyway
he's got about 45 more seconds he's
going to be brained in anyway
and you stop the blood with like your
finger
so he's got this balloon around the
heart compressing it because the
pericardial sac has got this small stab
wound in it but it's not leaking blood
so it's pushing on the heart so the
heart can't effectively block too much
pressure
pump blood to his brain so he's
out so then he's got this one single
hole but the hole's going
i just stitched it up with one stitch
it was like did that just i remember
while i was doing it thinking to myself
this is so
[ __ ] cool
and i guess the reason is because if he
died to be honest with you i don't know
him and he's expected to die with that
kind of injury right so if they're
expected to die and they die in your
hands you go yeah man i did everything
right and you died sorry about that
everything right except for
and this isn't necessarily you but how
do they not recognize as he comes in
that that one stab wound is actually
well what we would do well first of all
his brother's higher priority he's got
15 stab wounds and he's unstable this
guy's perfectly stable stable vital
signs you've got time so what you would
do is you'd get an ultrasound and see if
there's blood in the pericardial sex you
have time you don't open them up right
there for no reason so
okay was the
brother ended up being okay
the chubby brother um we operated yeah
he was okay just a whole bunch of stab
wounds thank god he was such a fat ass
no [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
yeah
it's true he he had he had a bunch of
stab wounds to a small intestine which
is like no big deal no big deal right
but was this guy just like died
and not so much after man i i uh as you
told the the story
about i i imagine god how cool would it
be if somebody took that and animated it
you know like totally animated you
telling the story and then it reminded
me of a question that was on my mind
much earlier in the conversation which
was
unbotched
um
the
the balance between showing what's going
on but not letting it be too graphic
yeah you know that's something that i'm
envisioning
for the mic for this multimedia comedy
show how much of a boob job can you show
like it's
well actually you can show it all i'll
tell you why the incision is so small
that the audience isn't really seeing
what the surgeon's seeing i thought that
i thought that a vasectomy is so
minimally invasive that the footage of
my vasectomy was underwhelming i got
full grown men passing out at almost
every show on my twitter but when you do
a vasectomy you you're actually exposing
the underlying tissue when you make an
incision only the surgeon can really see
in that hole beyond okay it's like a
dark hole in there okay so
job isn't that gnarly to watch not at
all
not at all yeah i mean it's funny
because on botched
they
blur things out and they don't show
necessarily a lot of graphic stuff but
when you watch dr pimple popper
the whole thing is the grotesque nature
of the popping of the pimples and they
show it all right so i guess because
it's not as serious or something it's
okay to show that
there's a weird type of person who wants
to see a pimple popped and i am not that
person yeah but i am we i don't know why
i love those videos
yeah i don't seek them out but it's a
big i don't look away it's a big show
it's big grotesque but they they don't
blur any of it but i guess it's not as
sensitive because you know they're not
there's nothing risk i don't know it's
interesting
all right man this is the day i stand by
this has been
the most fascinating
conversation i think maybe
and this has been fantastic well i
really enjoy it thank you guys so much
and just like that ladies and gentlemen
i have found my plastic surgeon boom
so stoked
and let me point out for those of you
who can see me right now that i'm in new
york city at this killer podcast studio
that you might recognize
from the flagrant podcast but what other
ones
uh a brilliant idiot
dad
we're in new york city baby and i'm not
telling you why because i legally cannot
yeah but holy [ __ ] this has been an epic
trip
um and for sticking around to the end of
the podcast you my friend are epic too
thank you guys so much
oh man it's starting to really [ __ ]
be bad
all right paul we're good man thank you
dog